الهزات مستمره هنا في الجنوب التركي لكنها
بدات تاخذ منحنى اخر الهزه الاخيره ضربت
منطقه نيدا ولايه نيدا وهي في وسط تركيا
غير بعيد عن محافظه والعاصمه التركيه
انقره كانت هناك هزه ايضا في سيفاس في
المحيط نفسه اي في وسط تركيا وهذا ما قد
يفتح الباب امام تساؤلات جديده هل خط
الصدى زلزالي الذي ضرب المنطقه الجنوبيه
هناك تحرك اخر في نقاط اخرى من البلاد ام
لا
الزلزال هذا هو المشهد يعني الدمار الذي
خلفه لا يزال هو سيد الموقف في مختلف
المناطق المتضرره وبالخصوص الولايات
الاكثر تضررا مثل هاتاي التي نتواجد فيها
ونتجول من شارع الى شارع لا شيء يرسم
الملامح هذه الشوارع غير اكوام واطنان
الانقراض التي تتراءى من كل مكان بالاضافه
الى المباني التي
تصدعت بشكل كبير جدا قد تبدو يعني قاومه
نوعا ما الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب المنطقه
في السادس من فبراير لكنه لكنها لم تقاوم
الزلزال الثاني الذي ضرب المنطقه مجددا في
خلال الاثنين الماضي فصارت تتهاوى هذه
الابنيه الواحده تلو الاخرى واتخذت
اجراءات يعني احترازيه مشدده من قبل الجيش
والعناصر الشرطه والدرك المنتشرين بكثره
في محيط هذه المدينه
لعدم السماح لاي كان من
الاقتراب من هذه البنايات او محاوله
الدخول ولكن احيانا نرصد يعني اشخاص
يخاطرون بانفسهم ويدخلون الى البيوت في
المحاوله الى يعني ان يخرجوا ما تبقى لهم
من اغراض نشاهد من هذا الجانب ايضا ان
هناك شارع شبه خالي بعد المباني لا تزال
يعني لم تسقط ولكن هي ايله للسقوط في اي
لحظه
هذه الهزات الاخيره يعني ادخلت نوعا ما
الرعب في وسط سكان ليس فقط الضحيه
الجنوبيه مثل ما قلت ولكن بدا الان
التفكير جديا في في هذه الهزات رغم
تطمينات الحكوميه
والاجراءات المتخذه للتخفيف من وطاه هذه
الكارثه